we co-founded open gov with the crazy
courageous naive vision that we could
power more effective and accountable
government and we're building the all
cloud all integrated erp for our
nation's state and local governments so
we're opening up the back office
bringing efficiency accountability
transparency to all these really
complicated workflows that touch our
daily lives
explain to the audience who doesn't know
what is an erp system
so
opengov offers budgeting and planning uh
software
minneapolis is defunding its police
department using our software tucson
arizona richmond virginia and suffolk
county new york and think of that as
ripping out the old oracle hyperion from
government we sell financial management
systems this is all the accounting and
tracking of where all the money goes all
the assets how they're recorded right
down to the paper clips and then
permitting licensing code enforcement
what we call our citizen services suite
so if you want to get a business just to
be clear is enterprise resource planning
enterprise resource planning and in
government it's all these transactions
and transactional workflows that very
few people think about but they actually
bang their heads against the wall both
in the government and as residents so
procurement and permitting and
financials and budgeting and then we put
it all in our reporting and transparency
platform so that's it in a nutshell
and so
explain to me and to the audience what
is the
example that is most common when you go
into
a government agency are you going into
city states towns the federal government
who's the target here and then what
would be the first two or three three
things they would do when they turn on
the software
so think about the mind run of the
cities and counties and towns that we
all grew up in there are about three
thousand counties in the united states
nineteen thousand cities and towns
there's actually another fifteen
thousand townships there's about twenty
thousand state agencies
many are too small to pay serious money
for high quality web-based software and
a few are so big they just want to hire
the accentures and deloittes of the
world and custom build things but
everything below the new york cities and
la counties and everything above the
little three horse towns in wyoming we
can serve with this incredible sas
platform
and so we help governments plan where
every dollar goes it's a major
anti-corruption device but they have to
build budgets and they have to get input
from the community and it's a big pie
fight on how to spend taxpayer dollars
and then we account for where every
dollar goes that's our financial system
and then if you need a poodle shaving
license or a marriage license or open a
business or outdoor dining permits or
you want to renovate your house all your
contractor needs building and planning
permits and all that is run through open
gov and our permitting and licensing and
code enforcement suite
and then which we call citizen services
and then we actually help governments do
their procurement so a whole range of
suites application suites to power more
effective and accountable government so
the classic playbook in sas has been at
least for the last two decades bottom-up
sass as david sac david sacks my bestie
perfected and created with yammer people
in the company would start using the
product and then eventually somebody in
the it department or management would
say oh what is this yammer thing we
should pay for it so we get more tools
in government i believe that doesn't
exist as a concept
so how did you
get product market fit and start
the product market fit journey nine
years ago with governments some courage
some naivete but you are right and and
david actually uh came by the company
fairly early and offered some advice and
help
governments don't accept free very well
governments you could have a magic
button that will run the whole city and
they don't have to do anything and
they'd be very hesitant to even press
the magic button so it's a complicated
enterprise sales process to get a
technical win with all their technical
personnel to get the political narrative
for the value creation and then of
course the commercials and so it's just
expensive to to sell into government
it's a huge barrier to entry
including for the governments but as our
co-founder joe has a lot of courage and
conviction they did this at palantir
and we've been building just bit by bit
you need a lot of product a sweet wins
versus best of breed
the old enterprise software contention
so the point solutions have a very tough
time because they can't get the price
points in government and the suites have
a tough time because it takes a long
time but you can charge higher prices
and pay for your sales and marketing and
product development so it's tremendously
complex and it's just getting better and
better as we get more and more software
more and more relationships we've got
over a thousand governments across the
country and growing multiple a week at
this point
and so what you're saying is people want
the microsoft office suite they want to
have the parking tickets and the permits
and the budgeting
and the payments all in one package they
don't want somebody to just sell them
parking meters and tickets and then
somebody else to sell them their
financial planning software one throat
to choke one procurement one support
line it just it they they want the one
including because we as a polity have
made it so hard for governments to buy
one of the reactions you get a
corruption scandal and then everyone in
town or everyone in the state says let's
put more regulation on governments and
how they spend money and their their
people say oh they're all incompetent
and dishonest so what do we do we put
more regulation on them and what does
that do it raises the price uh and the
cost and the time it takes to buy things
and we're running a company at opengov
i've got dozens if not 100 plus sas
subscriptions government has so
much technology that it needs and
literally even keeping track of their
vendors is a massive effort requiring a
lot of software across a huge range of
business lines the government is
basically just a holding company and
it's a weird holding company because
you'd never mix trash collection with
road maintenance with sewage processing
with electric power generations huh this
doesn't even make any sense from a
company perspective but that's what our
nation's governments generally are is
general purpose holding companies with
lots of different business lines with
huge ranges of workflows and needs
knowing what what is the worst situation
of inefficiency and red tape you've been
presented with on this journey and then
i'll ask what's the biggest win you've
had like in a very specific example so
both sides of the coin the biggest train
wreck and the biggest win there's some
spectacular and very sad really
government failures the city of bell
california the citizens were disengaged
and the mayor and city council
built hundreds of thousands and millions
of dollars from a small poor community
outside of la uh a spectacular
corruption scandal we actually went into
bell afterward and brought them
transparency software and helped them
try to build trust even the city of
cupertino had a serious corruption
scandal a dishonest staff member turned
out to have been stealing
they then brought in open gov budgeting
and planning to clean up the whole
budgeting process so that every dollar
is accounted for it's all tracked and
it's all open to the community and it's
been a huge success story in cupertino
right in the heart of silicon valley i
could go on and on about both some of
the
sad and incompetent situations we've
seen but also
just a lot of people working really hard
accountants lawyers public
administrators and managers across the
country fighting every day for their
communities and it's actually a more
positive story than most people think it
is
there's a lot more competence i would
say than most people realize going on in
their local governments so why do we
perceive it as so incompetent then
knowing what you know yeah you know
how much time and money do you spend
integrating a bunch of different
software products together at your
company let me guess way too much time
oh do is here to help odoo is a suite of
business apps that runs your entire
company on one platform they'll
streamline your workflow by bringing all
of that information together plus odoo's
integrations eliminate repetitive tasks
and data entry if you only need two or
three apps to optimize your workflow
that's all you pay for odoo won't stick
you with the bill for apps you don't use
odoo has an app for every business need
they offer 30 main apps that are updated
regularly in over 16 000 apps from their
active open source community you can
keep your books tight with their
financial software and their sales and
crm apps will help provide a clear and
organized view of your business so here
is your call to action your first app is
free forever and right now odoo is
offering a 1 000 credit on your first
implementation pack that's not a joke
that's a thousand dollars just go to
odoo.com twist to check it out that's
odo.com
twist
you